[Musique]
la journée de travail commence très tôt
dans ce marché de kigali
personne ne veut risquer de rater des
ventes les étals sont pleins de produits
frais qu'il faudra écoulés pendant la
journée et les clients se font parfois à
désirer mais dans cet entrepôt juste à
côté
le commerce est bien différent c'est un
marché de produits frais au 6 mai
version 2.0 ici les commandes se font
par internet et les denrées ne transite
que brièvement par l'entrepôt avant
d'être livrés chez clients à moto le
cybermarché existe depuis maintenant
quatre ans à kigali et compte déjà des
milliers d'usagers
surtout il a changé la vie de bien des
producteurs agricoles aujourd'hui en
contact presque directe avec le tient
notre motivation de départ était de
réduire les pertes de produits après les
récoltes qui peuvent atteindre 30 à 60%
avant d'arriver au consomac la
technologie nous permet de beaucoup et
la bi goua ce marché en ligne et la
création de haies est une jeune
entreprise typique de la nouvelle
économie dans le plus pur style de la
silicon valley avec ses employés rivés à
leur clavier tous
fraîchement sorti de l'université avec
ses bureaux à aire ouverte aussi ces
espaces de travail décontracté et ses
horaires flexibles
seule différence nous sommes en plein
coeur de kigali pour richard où ça les
nouvelles technologies représentent une
chance pour l'afrique mais quoi beaucoup
de rattrapage à faire sur le continent
est à nos yeux
les nouvelles technologies sont une voie
génial ou accélérer le développement
tous m'ont fast as
fondée il ya moins de dix ans par de
jeunes universitaires
une entreprise est déjà un acteur majeur
du commerce en ligne au rwanda ces sites
web se comptent par dizaines et les
produits vendus sont innombrables des
appareils électroniques ou sous
vêtements de l'alcool aux jouets pour
enfants thé même une pharmacie en ligne
et fournit un service clé en main
conseil conception du site service de
livraison 25 ans génocide le rwanda est
devenue l'une des économies les plus
dynamiques d'afrique avec un taux de
croissance de 8%
année après année et dans un pays
enclavé sans ressources
le secteur des biotechnologies est
appelé à prendre de plus en plus place
kigali ressemblent ces jours ci un
gigantesque chantier de construction les
gratte-ciels ultramoderne poussent comme
des champignons tout le pays et reliés
par fibre optique est couvert par des
réseaux cellulaires de quatrième
génération des habitants de kigali paix
maintenant leur transport en commun avec
des cartes sans contact ils peuvent
régler leurs factures d'électricité avec
leur téléphone et si le taxi moto reste
le meilleur moyen de se dépasser dans la
capitale de plus en plus de ces trajets
sont aujourd'hui informatisé cf moto est
un peu la version rwandaise de muller
l'application permet de commander un
taxi depuis son téléphone et les
chauffeurs sont localiser par gps
le concept a changé la vie de ce
chauffeur avant je passais la journée à
chercher des clients
maintenant les clients viennent à moi
directement sur mon téléphone
intelligent je gagne plus et je veux
fatigue - cette boutique de kigali
s'apprête à faire le saut elle aussi
dans la nouvelle économie où zouhri
conçoit et fabrique des sandales fait à
la main à partir de matériaux équitable
ou recyclés kevin keirin kundu n'avait
que 21 ans lorsqu'elle a créé son
entreprise
six ans plus tard et l'a déjà 57
employés
mais elle ne compte pas s'arrêter en si
bon chemin déjà présente sur les réseaux
sociaux l'internet représente à ses yeux
la clé du développement parce qu'on a
réalisé que la plupart de nos clients
utilisent des téléphones intelligents
des ordinateurs c'est là qu'il passe le
plus clair de leur temps
donc nos produits doivent être kevin a
donc fait appel à la société et pour
créer son site internet
[Musique]
bientôt tout son catalogue de produit
sera disponible en ligne
puis kevin ne cache pas ses ambitions
elle vise le marché international est
aussi voit grand l'entreprise continue
de porter la bonne parole numérique
elle a déjà formé des centaines de
stagiaires des ingénieurs en
informatique des graphistes des pros du
marketing et se voit déjà parmi les
licornes les prochains géants de
l'économie numérique